[Musique]
connaissez-vous ces parties de la
frontière pas avec cette partie pas encore
[Musique]
il y a un épisode d'hystérie à propos
des barbares j'ai des ordres d'obéir
[Musique]
je parle de situations particulières
situations où je sonde  pour la
vérité puisque tout ne va pas bien ici, je
m'attends à ce que d'autres mesures soient prises des
travaux mènent des opérations pour
corriger la situation que vous avez
permis de développer
qu'est-ce qu'ils vous ont fait vous voulez que
je vous ramène à votre famille les
barbares qui  vous poursuivez c'est
leur agneau ils en connaissent chaque centimètre
vous n'avez pas vraiment dit qu'il y
aura une grande guerre contre l'Empire la
douleur est la vérité c'est ainsi que vous l'obtenez vous
n'avez aucune idée de comment vous comporter vous êtes un
obscène  tortionnaire nous avons mis en place des procédures
prêtes à être intrusives Lee
fréquentant l'ennemi
sortez Je veux que ces gens sortent d'ici
[Musique]
nous mettrons fin à ces problèmes
[Applaudissements]
nous allons abattre l'ennemi
et ce sera la fin
[Applaudissements  e]
vous